Over the past several weeks, protests against racial injustice have made headlines around the United States and the world. People of diverse backgrounds are turning out in large numbers in small towns and big cities, incensed by recent high-profile instances where police have killed unarmed black people. For some white Americans, this movement may be prompting them to consider some for the first time, the white privilege they've benefited from all their lives. What can psychologists' research tell us about how, and why white Americans have long been able to ignore and even deny the advantages they enjoy merely for being white. How do white people distance themselves from their privilege in order to preserve it?
在过去的几周里，反对种族不公正的抗议活动登上了美国乃至全球的头条新闻。来自不同背景的人们在小城镇和大城市中大量涌现，他们对近期警察杀害手无寸铁的黑人的高调事件感到愤怒。对于一些白人美国人来说，这场运动可能促使他们第一次开始思考自己一生所享有的白人特权。心理学家的研究能告诉我们，为什么白人美国人长期以来能够忽视甚至否认仅仅因为是白人而享有的优势，以及他们是如何做到这一点的？白人是如何为了维护自己的特权而与之保持距离的？
And do they realize it when they do so? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday lives. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Brian Lowry, a senior associate dean and professor of organizing. behavioral behavior at Stanford University's Graduate School of Business. Dr. Lowry has studied the psychology of racial privilege in the U.S., including why white Americans are often blind to their privilege and how they react when it's brought to their
当他们这样做时，他们意识到了吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是斯坦福大学商学院组织行为学教授、高级副院长布莱恩·洛瑞（Brian Lowry）博士。洛瑞博士研究了美国的种族特权心理，包括为什么白人美国人往往对自己的特权视而不见，以及当特权被提及
attention. Recently, he published an op-ed in the Washington Post describing his own experiences of racial discrimination and calling on white Americans to support policies that advance racial justice. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Lowry. Hi, Kim. Thanks for having me. In your op-ed, you discussed the racism you've experienced, including being targeted with racial slurs as a child and being unjustly stopped and searched by police as a teen. You connect those experiences with your research on racial privilege.
时他们会有什么反应。最近，他在《华盛顿邮报》上发表了一篇专栏文章，描述了他自己遭受种族歧视的经历，并呼吁白人美国人支持促进种族正义的政策。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，洛瑞博士。你好，金。谢谢你邀请我。在你的专栏文章中，你讨论了你所经历的种族主义，包括小时候被种族歧视言论攻击，以及青少年时期被警察不公正地拦截和搜查。你将这些经历与你关于种族特权的研究联系了起来。
Why did you feel it was important to write this op-ed now and have this conversation? That's a great question, Kim. I wanted people to realize that this is just how common it is. And I think the recent videos and people's ability to... to see what's happening real time, it has increased that awareness, but I don't know that people have understood until recently just how common these kind of experiences are. And I wanted to turn the focus from what's happening to black people in this country to what that means about the experience of white people in this country. And so that's really what I thought was important
你为什么觉得现在写这篇专栏文章并进行这次对话很重要？这是一个很好的问题，金。我想让人们意识到这种情况是多么普遍。我认为最近的视频以及人们实时看到正在发生的事情的能力，提高了这种意识，但我不知道人们直到最近才真正理解这些经历是多么普遍。我想把焦点从这个国家正在发生的针对黑人的事情，转移到这对这个国家的白人意味着什么。所以这确实是我认为在此时
to write it at this time. Much of your research has been on how white people make sense of the unfair advantages that our society confers on them. In one paper, you talked about the three Ds, deny, distance, and dismantle, strategies that white people use to cope when confronted with evidence of white privilege. Can you talk a little bit more about those three Ds and the psychology behind each of those behaviors? Of course. So the first thing is that I think the psychology that drives it is a desire to feel like a good moral person. And in the context of a society that, explains our outcomes as a function of deservingness of meritocracy, it challenges our sense of self to believe that we might have benefited from unearned advantages. And in the case of race,
写这篇文章很重要的原因。你的大部分研究都是关于白人如何理解社会赋予他们的不公平优势。在一篇论文中，你谈到了“三个D”：否认（Deny）、疏远（Distance）和拆解（Dismantle），这是白人在面对白人特权证据时用来应对的策略。你能多谈谈这三个D以及每种行为背后的心理吗？当然。我认为驱动这种心理的第一点是希望成为一个有道德的好人的愿望。在一个将我们的成就解释为功绩主义（meritocracy）应得结果的社会背景下，相信我们可能从不劳而获的优势中受益，会挑战我们的自我意识。而在种族问题上，
the idea that being white has conferred unfair, unfair, unearned advantages can be incredibly uncomfortable. So I think that's the psychology that drives what we talk about and the deny distance and dismantle. And so what actually happens, how that's managed, it can't, very very. One thing that white people do is to deny that they personally benefit from white advantage or white privilege. And this is done in multiple ways. One common way is to highlight hardships they face. And while we think those hardships are legitimate, that everyone faces legitimate serious hardships. Hardships don't somehow absolve people of privileges or negate the existence of privileges. So that denial is an interesting strategy because it's as if you've gone through something
认为身为白人赋予了不公平、不劳而获的优势，这可能会让人感到极其不舒服。所以我认为这就是驱动我们所说的“否认、疏远和拆解”的心理。实际上发生了什么，如何管理这种心理，情况各不相同。白人所做的一件事是否认他们个人从白人优势或白人特权中受益。这可以通过多种方式实现。一种常见的方式是强调他们所面临的困难。虽然我们认为这些困难是真实的，每个人都面临着合法的、严重的困难，但困难并不能以某种方式免除人们的特权，也不能否定特权的存在。所以这种否认是一种有趣的策略，因为就好像你经历过
hard in your life that being white, therefore, doesn't confer advantages or privileges, or it's the idea that privileges or advantages means that life is always easy for you, where that's not at all the case. Right. And that's not the claim that we make. So that's the denial side. And the distance one is interesting because the distance allows for the existence of privilege, but simply says that I don't benefit from it. So it doesn't deny that privilege exists. It doesn't deny that it could exist for other people, but you really kind of separate yourself from other white people and say, I don't personally benefit, where denial is a way of sometimes denying the full existence of privilege. Meaning that nobody has white privilege. Right. So the example I gave was really personal,
生活中的困难，所以身为白人就不会带来优势或特权，或者这是一种认为特权或优势意味着生活总是轻松的想法，而事实并非如此。没错，那不是我们所主张的。所以这是否认的一面。而疏远的一面很有趣，因为它允许特权的存在，但只是说我没有从中受益。所以它不否认特权的存在，也不否认它可能对其他人存在，但你确实把自己和其他白人分开了，说我个人没有受益，而否认是一种有时否认特权完全存在的方式。意思是说没有人拥有白人特权。没错。所以我给出的例子是非常个人的，
but you also see this, the denial in the way where you see some people focusing on very successful black people, right, is a way of saying, look, they made it, therefore there isn't racial inequality. So there are other ways to get at that denial of privilege that it doesn't exist at all. And actually in this country, and so I think very recently, whites were claiming that they were at least a greater target of discrimination as black Americans are. So there's a lot of evidence that whites are uncomfortable with the possibility that white privilege exists at all and then further that they personally benefit from it. You've done research on how the way that you frame a discussion of racial inequality and
但你也会看到这种否认，即有些人关注非常成功的黑人，对吧？这是一种说法，看，他们成功了，所以不存在种族不平等。所以还有其他方法可以达到那种对特权存在的否认。实际上在这个国家，直到最近，白人还在声称他们至少比黑人美国人更容易成为歧视的目标。所以有很多证据表明，白人对白人特权可能存在，以及他们个人从中受益的可能性感到不舒服。你做过关于你如何构建种族不平等和
privilege affects people's reactions to them. Are there strategies to talk about racial privilege in a way that leads people to have a dismantle reaction rather than a denial or a distancing reaction? It's a good question. When people are willing to accept that privilege exists, there's reason to believe that they might actually support policies that dismantle it or work against it. And it looks like when people feel more affirmed in their self, when they feel better about themselves, it's easier to acknowledge the existence of privilege.
特权讨论的方式如何影响人们反应的研究。有没有什么策略可以以一种引导人们产生“拆解”反应，而不是“否认”或“疏远”反应的方式来谈论种族特权？这是一个好问题。当人们愿意接受特权存在时，有理由相信他们实际上可能会支持拆解它或反对它的政策。看起来，当人们在自我中感到更被肯定时，当他们对自己感觉更好时，就更容易承认特权的存在。
So that's what we do in a number of our papers. We show that when you affirm people's sense of self, when you give them an opportunity to talk about what they value, what's important to them, that they have an easier time acknowledging the possibility that privilege exists and that they might benefit from it. And once people acknowledge the existence of privilege, if you can get people to see that it exists, then there's a greater likelihood and a more, I wouldn't say comfort, but a greater willingness to support policies that dismantle that privilege. Well, let's talk for a moment about the invisibility of white privilege.
所以这就是我们在多篇论文中所做的。我们展示了当你肯定人们的自我意识，当你给他们机会谈论他们重视什么、什么对他们重要时，他们就更容易承认特权存在的可能性，以及他们可能从中受益。一旦人们承认了特权的存在，如果你能让人们看到它的存在，那么支持拆解这种特权的政策的可能性就会更大，而且会更……我不会说更舒适，但会更愿意支持。好吧，让我们谈谈白人特权的隐形性。
In a recent research article, you wrote that white people in the United States often don't even need to resort to the denial and distancing strategies we've talked about because of something you call herd invisibility. What does that mean and how does herd invisibility happen? It happens in part because society is structured in a way to hide the privilege that people benefit from. So you can see this in obvious ways, for example, segregation. Very few white folks in America actually have black friends and many fewer are living circumstances where they see the disadvantages of the racial inequity in our system. So that segregation allows for people to remain blind to their own advantages because they don't see the disadvantages that exist.
在最近的一篇研究文章中，你写道，美国的白人往往甚至不需要诉诸我们谈到的否认和疏远策略，因为你所说的“群体隐形”（herd invisibility）。这是什么意思，群体隐形是如何发生的？它之所以发生，部分是因为社会的结构方式隐藏了人们从中受益的特权。所以你可以从明显的方面看到这一点，例如种族隔离。在美国，很少有白人真正有黑人朋友，而且生活在能看到我们系统中种族不平等所带来的劣势的环境中的人就更少了。所以这种隔离使得人们对自己的优势保持盲目，因为他们看不到存在的劣势。
So they don't see the racial inequities. They blind themselves to the racial inequities simply, by the way, they go about their daily lives, right? They don't have to make a conscious choice. to ignore it so much as it's hidden, it's hidden from them by the way the society is set up. So that's one way that you get heard in visibility. And then each individual act that white people engage in to deny or distance actually serves the broader white community in that if I deny it exists and I create a narrative that it doesn't exist, then that serves you even if you aren't actively denying it yourself. And these are some of the cloaking strategies that you describe that people use to address some of the discomfort that they feel.
所以他们看不到种族不平等。他们仅仅通过日常生活的方式就让自己对种族不平等视而不见，对吧？他们不必做出有意识的选择去忽视它，因为它被隐藏了，被社会的运作方式隐藏起来了。所以这就是你获得群体隐形的一种方式。然后，白人为了否认或疏远而采取的每一个个人行为，实际上都服务于更广泛的白人群体，因为如果我否认它的存在，并创造一个它不存在的叙事，那么即使你没有亲自积极地否认它，这也对你有帮助。这些就是你描述的人们用来解决他们所感受到的不适的一些掩盖策略。
Yes. So again, going back to the underlying psychology, I think there's, when we talk about invisibility, it's an interesting and ironic way to talk about it because in reality, you have to be willfully ignorant not to see racial inequalities in our society. So the cloaking is a way of suggesting that what's happening is willful, but it doesn't require each individual person to participate at all times, right? So that's the herd immunity part or the herd invisibility part, rather. If enough people engage in it, then it hides it. It allows an active hiding from everyone. But it really is, this is what's, I think, often hard to convey that it really is an active hiding. It's not it's not that it can't be seen because it's not. the water we swim in, and that's sometimes how it's talked about. From my perspective,
是的。所以回到潜在的心理，我认为，当我们谈论隐形时，这是一种有趣且讽刺的谈论方式，因为实际上，你必须刻意无知才能看不到我们社会中的种族不平等。所以掩盖是一种暗示，即正在发生的事情是故意的，但它并不要求每个人时刻参与，对吧？所以这就是群体免疫的部分，或者说是群体隐形的部分。如果足够多的人参与其中，那么它就会隐藏它。它允许对每个人进行主动的隐藏。但这确实是……我认为这通常很难传达，它确实是一种主动的隐藏。并不是因为它看不到所以才看不到。它是我们游泳的水，有时人们是这样谈论它的。从我的角度来看，
it's the disparities are so great, so stark, and so easily accessible that there really has to be some process in place to allow us to not see it, that we have to engage in some psychological gymnastics as a society to deny its existence. And I think that's, Probably, well, not probably for white people, there's discomfort when they're not allowed to do that. And for black people and other people of color, it can be enraging to see people engage in these mental gymnastics in a way that allows them to ignore the pain of, say, the black community or other communities of color. Is the fact that so many white people are joining the protests, evidence that at least some white American, are engaged in dismantling, even if they don't know that's what they're doing? I certainly hope so. I should just say that I don't personally tend toward optimism.
差异是如此巨大、如此鲜明且如此容易获取，以至于必须有一些程序来让我们看不到它，我们必须作为一个社会进行一些心理体操来否认它的存在。我认为，对于白人来说，当他们不被允许这样做时，可能会感到不舒服。而对于黑人和其他有色人种来说，看到人们以一种允许他们忽视黑人社区或其他有色人种社区痛苦的方式进行这些心理体操，可能会让人感到愤怒。那么，有这么多白人加入抗议活动，是否证明至少有一些美国白人正在参与拆解，即使他们不知道自己正在这样做？我当然希望如此。我应该说，我个人并不倾向于乐观。
And some of that, I think, is realism. The history of the United States is littered with movements that in the moment seemed like they were gaining traction, but there's inevitably been a backlash to those movements. And that backlash tends to come when you move beyond simply the sense of moral benefit that people have from pointing out the pain that other people experience to the necessary work of actually changing the system, which comes at a personal cost. So the question will be when it comes out a personal cost, will the energy that we see now in the streets remain. And those personal costs mean giving up some of the privilege, right? I mean, you have to share some of the pie. Yes. I think that I think it may be hard for white people
我认为其中一些是现实主义。美国的历史充斥着那些在当时看起来似乎正在获得动力的运动，但这些运动不可避免地遭到了反弹。而这种反弹往往发生在你超越了人们通过指出他人痛苦而获得的道德利益感，转向真正改变系统的必要工作时，这需要付出个人代价。所以问题在于，当它需要付出个人代价时，我们现在在街头看到的能量是否会持续下去。而那些个人代价意味着放弃一些特权，对吧？我的意思是，你必须分享一部分蛋糕。是的。我认为白人可能很难
to fully understand the benefits of being white in the society. They can see, it's easier to see the pain that people of color experience and black folks in particular right now experience. I think it's harder to internalize and accept the degree. of privileges that are enjoyed as a function of the system. And the question, I think, will be when we really move towards trying to produce equity, are people going to be willing to give up those privileges? My sense and in some of my research, some of my research, I find that people can both acknowledge the existence of inequity, see that a particular.
完全理解身为白人在这个社会中的好处。他们可以看到，现在更容易看到有色人种，特别是黑人所经历的痛苦。我认为更难内化和接受作为系统功能所享有的特权程度。我认为问题在于，当我们真正走向试图实现公平的时候，人们是否愿意放弃这些特权？我的感觉以及我的一些研究发现，人们既可以承认不平等存在，看到某项政策会减少与这种不平等相关的差异，又诚实地觉得支持这些政策是不公正的，部分原因是人们将某些群体面临的劣势（比如黑人忍受的劣势）和白人享有的优势分开了。他们把这些事情分开了。他们说，让我们消除那些劣势吧。但当他们开始自己承担成本时，他们觉得这不公平、不正义。他们不明白为什么他们必须为别人的劣势消除付出代价。那么具体来说，白人需要做些什么才能完全拆解白人特权？这是一个很好的问题。其中一部分是支持真正重新分配
policy would reduce the differences that are associated with that inequity and honestly feel as if it's unjust to support those policies, in part because people separate the disadvantages that some groups face, like the disadvantages that black people endure and the advantages enjoyed by whites, they separate those things. And they say, like, let's just eliminate those disadvantages. But when they start to experience a cost themselves, they find that unfair, unjust. They don't understand why they should have to pay a price for someone else's, for the elimination of someone else's disadvantages. So in concrete terms, what is it that white people need to do to fully dismantle white privilege? That's a really good question. Some of it is supporting policies that actually redistribute
资源的政策。那将是一个很大的举措。这将是接受，并接受这个国家的教育系统从根本上，我个人认为从根本上是不公正的，并致力于推动反对诸如通过房产税资助学校等事情的政策，这可能会在短期内影响人们的房产价值。我认为仅凭这两件事，我会说，让我们从这里开始，看看进展如何。我还会考虑不要认为组织多元化不是让不合格的申请者进入，而是事实上，当你拥有我们现在拥有的那种特权时，你并没有真正获得人们获得机会的全部途径。真正从平权行动中受益的人是现在就在工作岗位上的人，理解这一点并接受它作为一种可能性。我的意思是，我认为这些事情会非常艰难，时间会证明，在对警察杀害黑人的愤怒情绪消退后，人们是否真的愿意走到那一步。美国人口普查局预测，到2045年，美国的白人人口将降至50%以下，国家将达到少数族裔占多数的状态。在你看来，这对白人特权的概念会有任何影响吗？这是一个好问题。好吧，这些预测已经产生了影响，对吧？
resources. That would be a big one. It would be accepting and accepting that the system of, say education in this country is fundamentally, I personally believe fundamentally unjust and working on policies that push back against things like funding schools through property taxes, which would have an effect on people's property values, perhaps short term. I think just with those two things alone, I would say, like let's start there and see how it goes. I would be also thinking about not understanding that diversifying organizations is not letting in unqualified applicants, but in fact, there's when you have the kind of privileges that we've had now, you're not really allowed the full pull of people to have access to
所以，耶鲁大学出色的社会心理学家詹妮弗·理查森（Jennifer Richardson）等人所做的研究表明，当你向人们提供这些信息时，白人往往会感到受到威胁，并以一种试图维持他们所拥有的特权的方式做出反应。当这种情况真正发生时，我认为如果我们现在还没有纠正社会中深层的不平等，我们将处于一个非常艰难的境地。届时，绝大多数的政治和经济权力将掌握在少数人手中。这并不是说这种情况在其他地方不存在，但我认为这是一个危险的境地。而且我认为这是可能的。没有任何迹象表明，仅仅是国家人口结构的变化就一定会消除与种族相关的特权。我预计人们会试图紧紧抓住他们的优势，甚至在他们开始看到这些优势受到挑战时抓得更紧。那么，拆除邦联纪念碑和重命名以邦联将军命名的地点，这种趋势在整个计划中是有帮助的吗？
opportunities. The people who are really benefiting from affirmative action are the people in the jobs right now, like understanding that and accepting that as a possibility. I mean, these are things that I think are going to be really tough, and time will tell if people are really good, are willing to go there after the energy of just the outrage over the deaths of black people at the hands of police passes. The U.S. Census Bureau has projected that America's white population will drop below 50% in 2045 and that the nation will reach majority minority status. In your view, will that have any impact on the notion of white privilege? That's a good question. Well, those projections already do, right?
还是这只是人们为了感觉良好而做的事情？这是一个好问题。我怎么看？我认为对于有色人种来说，这在象征意义上很重要。这在人们对自己物理空间的舒适感方面很重要。我认为这种象征意义对白人来说本身也很重要。它改变了很多吗？我不这么认为。
So there's research done by, say, Jennifer Richardson, an incredible social psychologist at Yale that shows that when you present people with that information, why it's often become threatened and respond in a way to try to maintain the privileges they have. When that actually comes to pass, I think if we haven't rectified the deep inequalities in the society right now, we're going to be in a really tough situation. where you will have the vast majority of the political and economic power in the hands of a minority. And it's not as if that doesn't exist in other places, but I think that is a dangerous place to be. And I think it's possible. There's nothing that suggests that simply the shift in the demographics of the country will necessarily eliminate the privileges associated with race. I anticipate people will try to hold on to their advantages and maybe even more tightly as they start to see them challenged. Is the tide toward pulling down Confederate monuments and renaming places that were named for Confederate generals, is that helpful in the scheme of things?
但我不知道我会不会把它仅仅贴上“感觉良好”的标签。我认为象征意义可以很重要，而且是有意义的。而且我认为拆除我所说的“白人至上”的偶像，因为很多纪念碑是在内战几十年后作为重申白人至上的一种方式而竖立起来的，拆除它们是象征性的，而且很重要。但这不会创造种族平等。美国心理学会刚刚发布了一项民意调查，发现绝大多数美国人，
Or is that just something that people are doing to feel good? It's a good question. What do I think about that? I think that for people of color, it's important symbolically. It's important in terms of people's sense of comfort in their own physical space. I think that that symbolism for white folks is also important by itself. Does it change much? I don't think so.
72%的人认为我们的国家处于他们所观察到的最低点。调查还发现，71%的人表示针对少数族裔的警察暴力是他们感到压力的重要来源。与此同时，超过三分之二的人表示，目前反对系统性种族主义和警察暴行的运动将导致美国的有意义的变革。鉴于你所做的关于白人特权和种族主义的工作，你对这些数字有多大的信任度？我的意思是，我是否认真对待人们对国家现状的担忧？以及他们是否真的认为这会导致有意义的变革？我认为人们现在很担心。
But I don't know that I would label it. but just a feel-good action. I think there's the symbolism can be important and is meaningful. And I think that pulling down icons of what I would call white superiority, because a lot of those monuments will put up much after the, you know, decades after the Civil War as a way of reasserting white superiority, pulling that down is symbolic and important. But that's not going to create racial equity. The American Psychological Association just released a poll that found a large majority of Americans,
我认为当你看到系统中的破坏时，这会引起合理的担忧。我认为人们确实相信事情会改变。我认为在某个时候很可能会宣布胜利。我有多认真地认为这种胜利会是真实的？这很难说。我对此不太乐观。所以我相信人们报告他们现在所经历的数字是诚实的。我认为这个国家旨在维持现状的机制极其强大。而且我认为人们可以从事维持现状的行为，并且在这样做时感到道德。我认为谁不想照顾自己的孩子，谁不想给自己的孩子他们能给的所有优势。
72% believe our country is at the lowest point they have ever observed. It also found that 71% said police violence toward minorities is a significant source of stress that they're feeling. At the same time, just over two-thirds said the current movement against systemic racism and police brutality is going to lead to meaningful change in America. Given the work that you've done, looking at white privilege and racism, how much credence do you give to those numbers? And meaning do I take seriously that people are concerned about the state of the country right now? And that they really feel that this is going to lead to meaningful change? I think that people are concerned right now.
如果我们只是这样做，我们就会维持现状。所以我认为彻底改变这个国家的种族等级制度所需的工作量是巨大的。虽然我对抗议和示威感到鼓舞，但我对我们还需要走多远的感觉是，我所拥有的任何乐观情绪现在都极其谨慎。你计划在白人特权这个话题上进行什么进一步的研究？我们还需要了解什么？我认为我们需要了解很多。现在，我的研究正在发生一点变化。
I think when you see the disruption in systems that causes legitimate concern. I think that people are, I think that people really do believe things. are going to change. I think that there's likely to be at some point the declaration of victory. How seriously do I think that victory will be real? That's harder to say. I'm less optimistic about that. So I believe the numbers in terms of people reporting, honestly, they've experienced right now. I think that the mechanisms in this country that are designed to maintain the status quo are incredibly powerful. And I think that people can engage in behaviors that maintain the status quo and actually feel moral while doing it. I think who doesn't want to take care of their child, who doesn't want to give their child all the advantages they can.
所以我对存在主义的担忧，我们如何理解自己以及我们如何在群体中进行社会理解，如何驱动我们的行为非常感兴趣。这包括群体间行为，身为黑人或白人意味着什么，身为美国人意味着什么，这如何驱动或创造我们的自我意识以及嫉妒地保护那个自我的愿望，这种基本的生存需求是如何驱动我们许多行为的。
And if we just do that, we'll maintain the status quo. So I think that the amount of work it will take to radically shift the racial hierarchy in this country is vast. And while I am heartened by the demonstrations and protests, my sense of how much further we would need to go is such that any optimism, any optimizations, any optimism I have is incredibly guarded right now. What further research are you planning on the topic of white privilege? What do we still need to learn? I think we need to learn quite a bit. Right now, my research is moving a little bit.
这就是我现在的状态。我有许多学生继续研究白人特权，但老实说，我的兴趣现在更多地转向了我们深层的生存需求是如何驱动我们的群体间行为的。这个话题在学生中反响如何？你在课堂上谈论它时会遇到很多阻力吗？这是一个好问题。老实说，我并不经常在课堂上谈论这个。
So I'm really interested in how existential concerns, how we understand ourselves and how we understand ourselves socially in groups drives our behavior. and that includes the inner group behavior, what it means to be a black person or a white person, what it means to be American, how that drives our or creates our sense of self and a desire to jealously guard that self, how that basic existential need is driving many of our behaviors.
所以我大部分时间在课堂上做的是领导力方面的工作。现在作为高级副院长，我在课堂上的时间更少了。所以我确实经常站在学生面前谈论他们的责任。在斯坦福工作，我们的学生既非常有才华，也非常有特权，正如我和所有与斯坦福作为学术机构以及许多其他真正精英和高地位学术机构相关的人一样。在这些群体面前，我说的是，当我们表现时，我们做出的决定会影响许多其他人。而且很容易专注于我们的决定如何影响我们的结果，它对我们的职业意味着什么，对我们的家庭意味着什么，而忽略了一个事实，即从我们的位置来看，这些决定实际上影响了许多人的生活。所以我并不特别谈论种族，但我试图给处于权力地位的人留下深刻印象的是，如果我们忽略了我们的行为对他人的后果，我们很可能会最终支持现有的不平等，对吧？加剧现有的不平等。这不需要我们成为坏人或种族主义者。它只需要我们继续顺应现状，或者继续试图最大化我们自己的结果。我认为我们有责任做更多的事情。
That's kind of where I am now. I have a number of students who continue to work on white privilege in particular but honestly my interest are now moving more towards how our deep existential needs are driving our inner group behavior. How does this topic go over with students? Do you find a lot of resistance when you talk about it in the classroom? That's a good question. I don't talk about this often in the classroom, honestly.
所以当我与学生交谈时，这就是我给他们的信息。我没有发现对此有太多的阻力。因为，同样，人们希望把自己看作是善良和有道德的人。所以我认为向他们传达这实际上对他们有什么要求是很重要的。而且我认为我们往往没有这样做。我们太关注个人种族主义或个人进步或任何事情，
So what I spend most of when I'm in the classroom, what I do is work on leadership. And now as a senior associate dean, I spend even less time in the classroom. So I do often stand in front of the students and talk about their responsibilities. So working at Stanford, our students are both incredibly talented and also incredibly privileged, as I and everyone else associated with this Stanford as an academic institution and many other really elite and high status, academic institutions. And in front of those groups, what I say is when we behave, the decisions we make affect many other people. And it's very easy to focus on how our decisions affect our outcomes, what it means about
以至于我们忽略了集体以及我们在系统中的集体责任。而且，这也是回到《华盛顿邮报》那篇文章的地方，如果你是一个腐败系统的一部分，你自己也会被腐败，对吧？所以如果你想维持或提升自己，那么你有责任去对抗你所生活的系统的腐败。
our career, what it means about our family, and lose sight of the fact that from our perch, those decisions actually affect many people's lives. And so I don't talk in particular about race, but what I try to impress upon people in positions of power is that if we lose sight of the consequences of our behavior on other people, we will likely end up supporting existing inequities, right? exacerbating existing inequities. It doesn't require us to be bad people or racist. It just requires us to continue to go along with the system as it is or continue to try to maximize our own outcomes. And that I think it's incumbent upon us to do more than that.
我想你给了我们很多值得思考的东西，洛瑞博士。感谢你今天加入我们。谢谢你的邀请。我很感激。美国心理学会的网站上有关于种族、种族主义和争取种族正义斗争的资源。请访问我们的网站 APA.org。你也可以在我们的网站 Speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客。
So when I talk with students, that's the message I give them. And I don't find a lot of resistance to that. Because, again, people want to see themselves as good and moral people. So I think it's important to convey to them what that actually requires of them. And I think often we don't do that. We focus so much on the individual racism or individual advancement or whatever
有关洛瑞博士工作的更多信息，请访问斯坦福大学商学院网站。你也可以在 Twitter 上关注他，账号是 @BrianLowryPhD。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。编辑和音响工程师是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Kondyin）。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
that we lose sight of the collective and our collective responsibility in the system. And also, this is what, in going back to the Washington Post piece, there, if you are part of a corrupt system, you yourself are gonna be corrupted, right? So if you want to maintain or elevate yourself, then it's incumbent upon you to push against the corruption of the system you live in.
我们忽视了集体以及我们在系统中的集体责任。此外，回到《华盛顿邮报》的那篇文章，如果你身处一个腐败的系统中，你自己也会受到腐败的影响，对吧？所以，如果你想保持或提升自己，就有责任去抵制你所处系统的腐败。
I think you've given us a lot to think about Dr. Lowry. Thank you for joining us today. Thank you for having me. I appreciate it. The American Psychological Association has resources available on our website on race, racism, and the fight for racial justice. Visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at Speaking of psychology.org. And you can subscribe to our podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
我想你给了我们很多值得深思的内容，Lowry博士。感谢您今天加入我们。谢谢你们的邀请，我很荣幸。美国心理学会的网站上提供了关于种族、种族主义以及争取种族正义的资源。请访问我们的网站APA.org。您也可以在我们的网站Speakingofpsychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》往期的节目。您可以在Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方订阅我们的节目。
podcasts. For more information on Dr. Lowry's work, visit the Stanford University Graduate School of Business website. You can also follow him on Twitter at at Brian Lowry, PhD. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. The editor and sound engineer is Chris Kondyin. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欲了解更多关于Lowry博士工作的信息，请访问斯坦福大学商学院网站。您也可以在Twitter上关注他，账号是@BrianLowryPhD。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。即speakingofpsychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。编辑和音响工程师是Chris Kondyin。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。